let's talk about what you've built what
does the tab do I've got a a simple
prototype you can see around my neck
right now it's kind of just like a
little little amulet pendant type shape
just a simple microphone on it Bluetooth
to your iPhone your iPhone sends it off
to the server all in background mode on
your phone you have like a mobile
interface and you can also kind of
communicate with this companion like how
would you actually build a UI of
something like her when you talk to it
it's just picking up any human voices 24
hours a day 7 days a week transcribing
everything creating language model where
you can ask it questions about every
conversation you've had the far more
interesting user interface Paradigm that
that I'm trying to explore right now is
how it can be proactive because it's
like always listening how can it like
hear something and then take action and
just save me time without me having to
do anything I just want to put a
necklace on it's kind of just like
reading your mind in a sense because
again it's building up this mental image
of who you are it understands your daily
routines know has an emotional Baseline
so it knows when you're kind of spiking
or kind of going off track